so donald trump really may not need to
steal this election we actually have the
latest 538 projection which says that
there's a 71
chance joe biden wins and a 29 chance
donald trump wins
you might recall those are very similar
numbers to 2016 and in 2016 of course it
went the way of the 29
so we're going to deal with that
tomorrow but the point is trump may not
need to steal the election but he's not
taking any chances
and he's going to try to steal it
because why not if you can do it why
wouldn't you do it now without redoing
my previous commentary
on the race being closer than these
double-digit polling leads suggest
i'll remind you when joe biden
is up nine in a poll with a 3.5 margin
of error
that means joe biden might only be up
two
in the popular vote with a popular vote
win of 2.2
in 2016 hillary lost so
i won't redo the entire commentary but
but the point is
when we see these leads for joe biden we
just we really have to assume nothing
and in fact the 538 forecast
which i'll go over in detail with you
tomorrow uh supports this
very very closely but what we should
know is this
is going to be an election that if trump
can steal it he's going to try to steal
it and we need to understand
all of the ways in which he's going to
try to do that first of all donald trump
has been saying oh this is going to be
an unfair
election he's trying to make it unfair
donald trump has been saying this
election will be rigged
well he's the one trying to rig it trump
has been saying vote by mail won't be
reliable
he's the one trying to make it
unreliable by kneecapping the post
office and ryan cooper
wrote a good piece uh this week in the
week in the publication the week
called donald trump is trying to steal
the election
and he outlines the various tactics and
strategies and approaches that donald
trump is employing and there's actually
a lot of them
and whether we can fight all of them at
once or how we do it is is sort of the
next question but we've mentioned some
of these before and i want to put them
together in a list so first of all i
mentioned this already
donald trump is trying to break the post
office the idea is
if people are going to vote by mail if
states are going to
expand absentee ballot access break the
post office so that it will be less
likely to succeed
in polls we've looked at trump
supporters
among those planning to vote in person
two-thirds are trump
voters among those planning to vote by
mail almost three-quarters are biden
voters so you see right away why trump
would try to break
the post office that's one strategy
number two
donald trump is trying to fine tune
and find time a stimulus a second
stimulus
so that it will be best positioned to
essentially buy votes and part of this
is that donald trump has said
uh i will defer payroll taxes
if he can right we'll see if he can
actually do it and
if you re-elect me i will make the
deferral
a permanent cut okay so he's effectively
saying
i will defer your payroll taxes for now
but unless you re-elect me when you file
your taxes next year
for this calendar year 2020 you will
owe the money you saved on the payroll
tax but
if you re-elect me i will make the
deferral a
forgiveness it it's trying to buy votes
the right
loves to say oh bernie's trying to buy
votes with free stuff
like health care which would be paid for
through taxes
this is really trying to buy votes
saying i'll defer i'll save you some
money for now you're going to owe it
back
in apr by april 15th of 2021
unless you re-elect me okay trying to
buy votes number three
donald trump is trying to delegitimize
the election
to weaponize his followers taking to the
streets
after november 3rd and it is working we
have a new poll which shows that
two-thirds of republican voters now
believe
that the election may not be fair i'm
going to talk about that later
in its own segment because it's so
important and and such a big deal and
really is the goal
of all of this donald trump is using
lawsuits
to try to turn the courts remember that
the courts
one of the biggest successes if you can
call it that one of the biggest
accomplishments of the trump
administration
is mostly thanks to mitch mcconnell's
help
getting two supreme court justices
confirmed one of which should have been
uh barack obama's selection merrick
garland
and getting hundreds of lower court
judges confirmed
so donald trump is using lawsuits and
he's being open about it he's talking
about we've got this in court we've got
that in court
he's trying to use lawsuits to turn the
courts
uh in his favor
after the election and to try to prevent
vote by mail so there's two two sides to
this
use the courts now to try to block vote
by mail in different states
and start laying the groundwork to
if there's a challenge after the
election have courts that maybe will be
more predisposed to rule in donald
trump's favor and you might remember
that for a couple weeks now donald trump
has been warning
it could take days it could take weeks
it could take months trump even said it
could take years to know who won
the november election that's not going
to happen but the point
is trump is trying to ensure
that it takes longer than it has to with
the lawsuits
with the destruction of the postal
service so on
and so forth now again trump might not
need to do this stuff
trump might be able to win without
suppressing the vote
without turning to fraud but it's
possible
that the only way trump can win is with
these tactics
and this very well could end up being
the craziest presidential election that
the us will have ever had at least in
the modern political era
so what do we do come on you guys know
what we do you know what we do we vote
early ideally um they can slow down your
ballot trump can slow down your ballot
by having louis de joy the new
postmaster general who is a trump donor
uh restrict overtime so that mail piles
up
in post offices look at trying to shut
down
some postal offices uh post offices or
or whatever
but if you mail in your ballot three
weeks early even if it's slowed down by
one two three four days it's going to
get there and presumably presumably it's
going to be counted unless trump figures
out a way
to mess with the actual election and
voting precincts themselves
they can close polling places but if you
plan
to vote early you will be less affected
by that so put the mask on or do the
mail-in thing or whatever let's do this
we know now that it is biden and harris
could not be more different than trump
and pence for all of the complaints we
might have about a lack of perfection in
this ticket and
certainly there are many and be aware
of when and where you can start to vote
early i'm going to talk about that a
little bit in the next segment but
a lot that we can do and a lot that we
should be doing
if you love feeding your intellectual
curiosity but you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my all-time
favorite apps called blinkist blinkist
lets you consume an entire book
on your way home from work they take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
condense each one into text or audio
that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's
perfect if you don't have enough time to
do all the reading you want to do
or if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire thing
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription is only
about eight bucks a month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
percent off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video